Newton's third law states that forces
always come in equal and opposite pairs
one way we can write that is if you
imagine two objects object one and
object to the force exerted by object
one on object two is equal and opposite
to the force exerted by object two on
object one this makes explicit that real
forces always arise from a physical
interaction for any force in a problem
you should always be able to identify
the other member of the interaction pair
Newton's third law is the most subtle
and sometimes the most confusing of his
three laws of motion so I'd like to do
an example that will help clarify how to
think about it so I'm going to pick a
very extreme example let's imagine the
collision between a marble moving this
way and a train moving that way and so
we'll say that the mass of the Train
I'll write that as M sub train and the
mass of the marble is M sub marble and
obviously the mass of the Train is much
larger I'm going to write that as
several greater than signs much much
larger than the mass of the marble okay
and so the question I want to consider
is at the instant that these two objects
collide which experiences the greater
force so think about that yourself for a
moment
in terms of outcomes clearly the marble
will be smashed by the Train whereas the
Train will not be noticeably affected by
the marble so your intuition might
therefore suggest that it's the marble
that feels the greater force but that's
incorrect because Newton's third law
tells us that forces come in equal and
opposite pairs and what that tells us is
that each object will exert an equal but
opposite ly directed force on the other
now I chose a very extreme example
to your attention but that might seem
like a surprising result but Newton's
third law tells us that the forces on
each object are going to be equal and
opposite but just because the forces are
equal doesn't mean that the motion will
be equal the accelerations of the two
objects are vastly different because if
there are different masses and the
accelerations and the forces are related
by Newton's second law F equals MA so if
I write that in terms of the
acceleration the acceleration of the
marble a marble is equal to the force
divided by the mass of the marble
whereas the acceleration of the Train is
equal to so since I wrote F for the
force acting on the marble I'm going to
write minus F for the force acting on
the Train so that's minus F divided by
the mass of the Train and so if I want
to look at the ratio how big is the
acceleration of the marble divided by
the acceleration of the Train and let's
take the absolute value so we're just
talking about magnitudes here that's
going to be equal to the mass of the
Train divided by the mass of the marble
but the mass of the Train is much much
much larger than the mass of the marble
so the right-hand side here is a very
very big number and that tells us that
relative to the acceleration of the
Train the acceleration of the marble is
going to be enormous even though the
force experienced by each object is
identical because of their different
masses that are accelerations will be
very different so that gives us an
example of what we mean by Newton's
third law in terms of the interaction
pair and equal and opposite forces
acting
I want to reiterate that for any force
in a problem you should always be able
to identify the other member of the
interaction pair so forces always come
in pairs it's important to keep in mind
that these force pairs don't both act on
the same object they never act on the
same object the interaction pair always
involves a pair of objects two different
objects and let me just make that
explicit
with an example the example I'll
consider is imagine a person standing on
the ground what are the forces acting on
this person I'll draw the force diagram
here say there's gravity mg acting
downwards and there's a normal force
upward exerted by the ground and those
two balance to give a net force of zero
which is why the person is standing on
the ground and not you know sinking down
into the ground for example now you
might look at gravity and the normal
force I'm wonder if those are an
interaction pair and they're not because
notice that these two forces are both
acting on the same object the person the
interaction pair always comes from
realizing what is exerting the force on
the object so let's look at each of
these in turn
gravity is exerted by the earth so if
the earth and this means really the
entire Earth exerts a force mg on the
person Newton's third law tells us that
the person exerts a gravitational force
on the entire earth of mg upwards now
that might seem remarkable to you if
you're just standing around on the floor
that you are exerting a gravitational
force on the planet but you are however
this is like the example we just talked
about a moment ago the masses are
extremely different even though the
forces are the same so the acceleration
of the earth due to this person's mass
is negligible because the earth is so
much more massive than the person but
Newton's third law tells us that there
is a tiny acceleration on the earth due
to the person
that is the third law pair for gravity
mg downward exerted by the earth on the
person is paired with mg upward on the
earth exerted by the person now for the
normal force acting on the person that
force is exerted by the ground so the
ground observes an upward force n on the
person Newton's third law tells us that
that means that the person must exert a
downward force n on the ground that is
the interaction law is the interaction
pair for Newton's third law for the
normal force